but lo how I actually ended up taking it
and sitting here right now exactly if
you guys are just tuning in now do you
guys miss group oh my gosh me go back
and watch that later you're going to
love it but right now we've got full Sun
versus low hi fate versus UI u UI u
another one of those companies another
one of those teams putting a lot of
effort into making sure that their tech
and squad is top-notch I mean they got
double thing they have low high I mean
what more can you expect and lower one
of those guys right you they have so
many great players and I feel like low
high is one of those players that I look
at he's always trying to get better
always striving to be just the perfect
specimen of a player so he can be the
best and here we go oh hi vs. old sod
kazumi vs. Shaheed right out of the gate
yeah he'd get the grab that's such an
odd opening choice and it worked out
going for the lows this time around
great punch don't break our bones yeah
weird right bull airs not break it's
over in a bit guys forget it let's test
the more throws
Oh counter-hit put a block on the low
how did he know Oh sod is ridiculous
what you know he's very young right look
super young
what do you see him do those kind of
blocks like for front of me oh you live
you see the can be ace like down in the
air mix up you know you made him think
about real long he's like slightly oh oh
there's some kind of an issue low high
kicks off the headphones points at the
monitor I'm gonna try to resolve
something here I'm gonna get one of our
my team members on the stage see what
the problem is here but that match was
going back and forth there and both
players had those weird throws I'm not
really sure it happened looks at the
game so running so I don't know what
happened yeah I think they're just
discussing it to make sure you know when
things like this happen especially in a
tournament like this you want to make
sure that it's you know on both sides
both of these guys understand what's
happening we already got somebody on the
stage to help him out but yeah man just
talking about the fact that you know
lohi representing you why you had that
ridiculous every way so good like I know
that he deserves to be here after that I
really wanted to see a way honey come up
in this top transect I believe his name
is Mauro I was talking to out there me
oh shout out to him and he definitely
say Pakistan was yelling against the
entire class so awesome the entire crowd
he just Turner like no Pakistan
everybody it was sick that's the kind of
passion you want that's the kind guys
you want on your something that mastered
you okay we just we went up there
because we want to root for Jimmy J
right like we gotta get close to Jimmy
can here this is like four of us there's
like a billion everyone else and so
we're sitting up there with cheer for
Jimmy J and then we were sitting right
behind the pack damn players and then
you know of course Jimmy's out of there
and now it's just a wise honey versus
low high and we're kind of cheered with
that restroom but then at the end of it
you know they're diluting and getting
quieter and rich is like nah man you
gotta keep going no matter what right
anyway the final final round down the
wire that match couldn't bend it any
closer right low high wants like the
tiniest pixel the tiniest pixel it was a
nail-biter no matter what
it's that entire group play it was so
ridiculous it meant so perfectly I met
up to the standards where here we go
that one round already back in and we're
going straight back old sign low high
round number two game number one
losers side top eight of course this is
two out of three chance you guys back up
yeah old son man he's gonna so clutch
with that magic for all day today boy
check in the shins while standing one
down three completely wisp all sides
like that getting out game just to see
the baby throw high to with it's more
perfect so yo this guy don't block low
what this Mooreville I'm the down Jeff
interrupts their perfect option beats
both of it and the high low high trying
to hold his ground right now all stop
playing slow moving heavy right now
it's sharp right now a little in and out
- look at what he's doing he's trying to
get low high to swing at something he
knows Lord likes to do that he'll play
so disrespectful with time he'll just
dunk in your face try to get you to you
know react he'll eat a slide or hop kick
nice counter hit confirm right there
round away from getting his first game
here at fight boots on is trying his
hardest to make low height horsies wish
but he's really not getting many out of
them oh nice flash punch combo check the
downpour ones of course the Kazumi
specialist lo Perry I seen enough of
those loans better stop it being surf on
crew right your leg nice move that back
one sliding extended this lines been
working out but here it comes
oh just come into it while I trying to
shake it off final round Game one and
just a pixel of pixel of life game
number one tied up man sliding get that
free follow up with that down for for a
double down for four
oh okay now let him go close anymore
you let him have a few of them
pronounced final round situation big
leap below high man is back and forth
this all get in the bowl Perry once
again surf on it
that's gonna be the one lohi takes that
first game and man it's it's definitely
really cautious they can make it a lot
of these answers in these small mistakes
it's what's giving like the momentum to
like low high because low high is one of
those players he's very much a momentum
player I feel like old sign just waits
for that perfect moment to strike
so these guys have clashing Styles I
still can't get over the fact that both
of these guys are in the loser bracket
here both of them more in their
gooseneck they look kind of like
favorites in their group to make it out
but like maybe not of the winter side
but man here they are old so I'm
thinking about it coming out on that in
that losers side I completely forgot
about that that old sign only made it
out of that lose his side yeah when you
looked at that pool and you watched it
you felt like you wanted
yeah the way he was playing it was so
ridiculous I'm looking at I'm like oh
man I forgot oh my god yeah and
everyone's talking about kazumi after
the season three changes but then he was
like no it's fine no exactly okay as you
can see with him continuing to pick
kazumi I mean we saw pull out that bob
earlier to actually got the first game
against our Celyn edge - yeah that's a
great point you know we're not seeing -
Bob out of him right now putting his
tournament life honest kazumi here
against low high low high my head in the
set runs up and starts to check with
that down 4-1
yeah mission went dojo at this time -
choice for old sign man
oh yeah he's getting loose now he's
started to open up the rhythm of lore I
get the running - lots of folks working
out in old signs favor - one get the
wall flat and the real lot confirmed off
the down back to fellow I are always so
good oh the line trouble we is a raged
old break on the throw what's the kiss
no rage for both alike so get in the
range of it so it's all time
Wow doing extend across it just slides
so many times this that wouldn't the big
mix this is exactly what I was talking
about he will walk up in your face duck
and you're like what is he going is this
slide is it hop kick foot it I mean when
you go against the crowd you gotta be
quick with a minute there it was all
sounds like I'm not waiting for you
anymore it's in hockey - talked about
those young man reactions there they go
great adaptation immediately that time
hold on has the lives back to the wall I
mean I was working on a perfect that
around so crazy come back at Doug's it a
nice punishment from Wilson there we go
and he's staying focused here
he knows you let that first round slip
away I said while Fanny one once again
loja pulling out the folks of his own
down three goals for the slide
watch out sidestep and still got clipped
drop it on them the tires all over low
high right now trying to get that life
lead back running to his bluff low eyes
back to the wall that puts them in rage
after the jump it down to a little bit
down to potage is needed here oh great
tracking me in right there nice stutter
step right there old sign on to
overcommit
low my interrupting the fly mix-up hit
confirm and low I is so good at hit from
that down back to and just like that
it's gonna be set point below high here
who thought facing elimination from the
tournament in trouble hoping to mount
nice lost 94 for there trying to keep
them out that Jam those slides have been
working out wonders maloha almost
definitely here's the stats kicks
returning now below I've got the lead
old signs a little bit of trouble your
finds the running - you can see him he's
just doing those little fake ducks up
close like to hold me back in the jab
their hands off and your ground oh you
know oh no probably just how the game
started for these guys then get up 50
feet down
and hold on get it tight enough that
could have went either way but hold on
is still in the tournament right now I
feel like I can't breathe
oh my gosh it's so tense man we're back
you messed the players on the stage
taking the instant run it back
final game incoming one of these guys
will not be here one of these guys is
going home ladies and gentlemen not
forget the $250,000 prize bull a lot on
the line for all these matches Lowell I
stopped at the pressure just with the
down for see him put pokes out there to
stop that approach of all time but his
get them clip yeah hold on man he is
changing things up here companions
leopard jackie but there is the hockey
daddy something he has not gone to and
the wall can be right there frosted
flakes
that's the racetrack get off it's a mint
it's a flash punch combo toe kick keep
them away oh my gosh
that could have went either way Oh
get the first round here in Game three
down three completely whips now for once
you want to punish and look at this
office once the game from old sign he's
trying to push through the wall loja do
something nightfall shut it down for to
close up getting a little ahead of
himself that time low high getting the
punished on the flash punch combo after
hold on overextended
oh my god what is up your man so many
risks goals for the hop kicked off and
it's working out if the floor launcher
has to punish look at the damage on the
wall break their legs and do it yeah
all son is cracking under pressure right
now one round apiece low eyes guys they
focus bolt saw it's got to pull it back
together three loja push it back to this
wall now like manage oh nice all son I
love these you see the three combos I'm
Sam from kizomba
a running to all the wall for three for
the whit punished found its market now
huge me for old sod
Polk and champ get up the race drive
good spacing there dancing a little bit
they like the music to Hirata mm-hmm
can't blame them loses the round because
of it this is set point for old side low
high endanger it going home unfortunate
from their stead expend encounter it
those little false sense of security
Doug's right there make it you react to
the wrong thing that's how low high gets
his openers in a lot of these instances
a lot better than most no these guys are
both a little bit nervous right now
Bulls don't got leave but he's the one
falling behind here almost 30 seconds
left on the clock and that's what I was
talking about those ducks just right at
point-blank range low high scouts them
out get to launcher because of it all
side knows this and let me get the
opportunity but the down for two on the
punish old songs hand hovered above you
stick like oh boy I made a big mistake
and [ __ ] like that
final final round bait old son you are
you lowlife losers bracket top mate
somebody's about to go home Oh statue
kick
beep it's coming from Ulsan one foot
above the toy
look at this defense l200 down three
with the rake this time he's so clutch
with rage didn't pull the trigger at
that time let's it rip
there it is old Sun will be taking it
over low high he will be going home and
that's the Evo champion guys guys make
some noise but low ha he will be going
home but one of the better players out
there I've seen all season long
I mean I'm just a huge fan of gin [ __ ]
holes I'm one of those guys like I said
a lot of people I feel like they kind of
forgot about a pig that he raised in
prime position to still be alive in the
finals and that was so crazy about this
TD files in particular and you had the
19 top which we didn't know was good
when the LCQ
but these 19 players were so good it was
the most stack tournament roster we've
had potentially ever for the twt look so
many people and we've been doing this
we've been kind of like on the trail
right we've been to all at least taking
world ton tournament matches and people
like who do you think is gonna win who
do you think is gonna win I'm like I
don't know that everybody's way too good
you know so what do you do about that I
can't answer those questions yeah I have
no idea but let's take a quick look at
the bracket you know the bracket is